CACAPIPITATALILIZEZEDD O ONN E
ONON  DIDISPSPLALAY.Y.
SPSP
SHSHOTOT. .
IMIMPOPORTRTANANT.T.
>>>> J Johohn:n: G GARARLALANDN
THTHTH O OPEPENININGNG
PEPERIRIODOD T THIHISS T TEAEAM
BRBRISISSESETTTT T TO O THTHEE
REREJEJECTCTEDED B BYY M MARARK
OPOPENEN U UPP T THIHISS F FOUO
>>>> J Johohn:n: GAGARLRLANAND
SWSWITITCHCHEDED O ONN T TOO B
HEHERERE H HEE G GOEOES S TOTO
2020  POPOININTSTS. .
1717 B BIGIG  REREBOBOUNUNDSDS.
MOMORERE I IMPMPORORTATANTNTLYL
HEHE G GIVIVESES W WAYAY T TOO
WAWATCTCHEHEDD B BYY  BRBROGOGD
ONONCECE A AGAGAININ S SWIWITCTO
THAT'S THE INFORMATION YOU
>> OR HE DELIBERATELY MISSTHIS
PLAYS.REBOUND, JOEL. CLOCK AT 5
I SHOULD SAY AT.
>> I STOP RIGHT THERE.
FOUL BAL
GOT T
THAT KIND OF RICOCHETED OFF THE
THE ANGLE IT TOOK OFF THE GLASS
O IT HERE FOR YOUR
THIRD QUARTER.
WHAT A FRAME IT WAS FOR  A LITT
NOT AS DECICI
THERE'S AN AUDIBLE GASP IN THE
BUILDING. ONE AND GO RIGHT TO
THE   TEAMS THE
KINGS ARE 28th IN FINDS
FOURNIER.
MITCHELL DID A
>> Clyde: LOOK AT THE COHESION
BY THE KNICKS, THE THE  HOUNDIN
SPINS INTO THE FRONT
COUR
WITH THE THREE
GOOD BALL DENIAL THERE.
McBRIDE HAS BEEN EXCELLENT
D
LOOKING FOR RANDLE.
RAND GETS IT TONDOR ON THE LEFTH
>> Clyde:
TRAILING BY 20,, JULIUS RANDLE
BASICALLY
POSTED AND TOASTED HIM. McBRIDE.
.
DOESN'T, BUT GETS T T RANDLE.
RANDLE EXCELLENT FIRST
HALF.
RANDLELEBASKET.
BURKS PICKS UP HISIS
WINDS DOWN INTO THE LANE, NO.
AND SENGUN LOSES THEMALIK MONK
REALLY GOOD GAME.
AND FOLLOWS.
HE FEATHERS IN THE THREE.
LEAD WAS A CALL THAT HAT WE HAV
ANOTHER 20-POINT SCORING GA>> N
POSSESSION.
>> LOST IT.
ON >> IT'S THE
PORTIS HAS BEENOACH IN NBA
HISTORY, PASSING ICONS.
I C LAST
NIGHT, RESEARCH.
>> Jef
BENCH.
MIDWAY THROUGH THE SECOND.
GOLDEN STATE
>> Mike: WELL, JEFF, HOW ABOUT
THISIS
WHO SAYS, THAT'SIR
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> Mark: THINKNK
HIM AND HE DROVE IT BASELINE,
BROUGHT THE SECOND
LEAD BACK UP TO 14.
FOULED BY ALLEN.
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE FOURTH
TEAM FOUL.
MOMENTUM BACK AND THAT LED TO
SOME STOPS DEFENSIVELY.
>> Lisa: A QUIET
>> Mike:ND CURRY,
THE THREE OF THEM OUT THERE,
MAKES IT SO DIFFICULT FOR THE
DEFENSE. MORE.
>> CasH QUARTER
AGAINST MEMPHIS,INTS.
MIDRANGE ON THE WAY.
KEEP WORKING OFF THAT GUY AND
YOU GET NOW.
>> Doris: TWO GUYS WHO MAKE THE
GAME LOOK SO EASY.
GUYS.VE
IMPROVEMENT FROM A COUPLE MONTH.
A RARE MISS GOT IT.
>> Doris: THIS SPEAKING WITH O
WITH THAT BUCKET, HE REACHES
MARCUS, YOU HAVE TO GUARD HIM, .
>> INGRAM IN THEBARTON.POINT
BARTON AROUND THE CORNER.
INSIDE, BACK TO
NO-MAN'S-LAND.
SCRAMBLING COMPR ARE
EGREGIOUS.
THERE ARE SO MANY TONIGHT, BUDD!
LONG PASS, MORRIS HAS 1
AROUND.
GORDON. INGRAM.
FAKE GAME TO CATCH THE DEFENSE .
AUSTIN RIVERS AND JOKIC HELPING
OUT REBOUNDS.
JOKE PAINT AND HE
FINDS WAYS TONE-POINT ADVANTAGE.
>> YEAH.
VALANCIUNAS, RIGHT AROUND NIKOLA
JOKIC RIGHT THERE.
ONHE CLOSEOUT.
STILL WAS THERE.
A GOOD NUGGETS' PACK
>> JOKIC HAS RECOGNIZED. TAKINGG
FRANCE
>> 122-118.
NUGGETS F GO FORLED OUT IN THE
FOURTH QUARTER.
JOKIC, 39-11-12.
CAN THE NUGGETS JOKIC.
CAN ANYBODY STEP UP WITH NIKOLA.
THEY DOUBLE.
MORRIS NEARLY TRAVELED.
KYKYRIRI E EQUQUALALIZIZERER..
4242 F FOROR F FININISISH.H.
3939 F FOROR K KYRYRIEIE F FORO
JUJUSTST A A L LOTOT O OFF B BE
TETEAMAMMAMATETE O ONN H HIMIM.
IRIRVIVISIONONON P PUTUTSS I IT
## L LIPIP..
ITIT'S'S A A V VERERYY A COUPLE
SHOTS.
HE IS REALL GOT
A HORN SOUNDING FOR
>> Brian: IT WASN'T A P PED SOME
OR MAY JUST BE TIRED.
>> Brian: AND TOOK ONE OFF THER6
ASSISTS.
IT WOULD BE ALL
OF THE THIRD.
NUGGETS IN THE SURGED. DOWN.
>> Stan: AND
SECOND DEFENDER.
20,000 POINTS IN HIS NBA CAREER.
WARRIORS A CHANCE TO TIE OR TAKE
THEKIC.
JOKIC HAD IT KNOCKED OUT OF HIS
HANDND THE
LEAD.
CURRY TRYING TO SHAKE JEFF
GRGR
AGAINST GOLDEN STATE.
WIDE OPEN ANDULD COME DOWN
AND LOOK FOR AN ALLEY-OOP.
INSTEAD, IT'S LEBRON TOOK HIFOR
THROWS IT DOWN. KAREEM
ABDUL-JABBAR GOT LESS THAN 200
NOW TO CATCH ASKED KARL MALONE
AND WE'RE SPEAKING TO
GET THAT DEFENSIVE REBOUND.
LEBRON S
AS ANYONE EXCEPT FOR  COMES THE
DOUBLE BY
COURSE, LEBRON. HE STARTED AT
THE 5 TONIGHT, THAT DEPARTMENT
YEAR. ALL THE CLUTCH GAMES.
THEY HAVE BEEN GREAT. ERE HE
COMES. LEBRON. NG TO BACK UP
LOCKS DOWN TO 3 LEBRON OVER
KUZ. AND LEBRON'S 3RD, 40
POINT GAME HE'S UNDERNEATH.
MAKE
>> FALL BACK. YES. MIDDLE MAN,
HERE, HE GOES SPINNING ALL THE
WAY. KIND OF IT GOES. WORK IT L